you had no money no connections and no  experience what would you do to dominate  as fast as possible the last part is the  problem that word fast is your  kryptonite  now what is the most strategic thing  that may give you the potential for it  to happen faster-ish is documenting the  process of learning through youtube  shorts tik-tok and facebook fan page the  authenticity that you're learning  documenting meetings with some you know  veterans in the game will be so  endearing for the people on the other  side you will actually have people that  reach out to and say i want to give this  kid a shot biggest thing i tell kids is  don't fake it like the faking to make it  thing is a problem just because you  dress the part doesn't mean you are the  part being authentic and saying the  journey of becoming versus saying the  young buck that knows when people can  tell that you don't tricking yourself is  a losing formula